trend auction started to pour it on here
up by 16 and a foul coming and now Ariza
and Trey young starting to have words
and trevor ariza still involved betray
it now security comes out they're going
to separate the two clubs
there's going to be a video review here
and let's see what happened on the
sidelines yeah he tried to go through
his legs and a reason didn't care for
that at all
the personal foul was called on a reason
eighty-nine 73 is our score some of the
veteran guys it raises sixteen years to
this league he didn't care for that no
you know they take it a little personal
right between the legs and he stepped
right in the path of trade to give him a
nice little shot
[Applause]
so the officials check with replay my
guess is they're checking for a possible
hostile act they haven't really said
anything but they may be just upgrading
the file to a flagrant it is a flagrant
one on a reason
[Applause]
no reason still out there dead sailor by
his side and a Reese's waiting at
midcourt he's carrying out a
conversation with a Hawks bench yeah you
know he didn't like that at all and he's
still in conversation with Jeff and
Treveon Graham so Trey to the foul line
with the lane vacated Lakewood one
charge to a reason
[Applause]
seventy-four tray